two of the suspects were subdued by the
officers using Tasers
police
in fall 2011 Jack Kephart led a rally on
behalf of his late son Alan we are
having a protest march for my son
against the San Bernardino County
Sheriff's Department
the Kephart family is suing the
department for wrongful death after
three officers allegedly tased Alan cat
part multiple times in the upper back
neck and head during a traffic stop in
Lake Arrowhead California I feel that
that my son was murdered I think
something has to be done about law
enforcement most definitely the Taser
did have that's what killed him
police related deaths like Allen cap
parts are pushing activists families and
courts to question whether tasers or
officers are to blame tasers typically
fired two probes into a subject that are
attached to electrical leads and then
apply a voltage meter b-bring is a
senior staff attorney at the American
Civil Liberties Union of Southern
California if you just pull the trigger
they'll apply a five second cycle so
it's 50,000 volts at a very low current
but it's enough to capture the muscular
system and and cause a person to spasm
fast and paralyze the person usually
if you see videos on YouTube a person
will lock up and fall to the ground even
Taser International makes those videos a
part of its advertising campaign drivers
incapacitate dangerous subjects safely
end armed standoffs the special and next
taser can even stop aggressive large
animals without injury while a taser
delivers that much force the question of
whether tasers are in themselves safe is
a tricky one studies have come to a lot
of different conclusions and some have
links to the company themselves and
those that look at criminal law say it's
all relative I mean a taster can be
safer it can be unsafe it depends on the
circumstances in the case Laurie
Levenson is a former federal prosecutor
and she says that at one time tasers
were considered a step toward using less
force on the street we can remember back
to cases like the Rodney King case and
in fact they did try to use a Taser
there and it didn't work when we had
police using so much force it was almost
lethal and at that time many of the
police departments started to take a
look at what their options are they
didn't want to be using the gun that is
lethal force and the other options seem
to be the Taser by the year 2000 around
5000 law enforcement correctional and
military agencies were using tasers in
2011 that number climbed to over 16,000
we've all seen the pictures of Los
Angeles police officers beating a man
they had just pulled over and after
high-profile excessive force instances
like Rodney King police departments
needed to show they were making an
effort to scale back force departments
are eager to adopt things that promised
to be safer for officers safer for the
public the problem that we have with
tasers is that law enforcement
departments and personnel that are told
or or trained that tasers are perfectly
safe that they cannot cause harm are
likely to use them in circumstances
where they would never consider it using
more serious force like a gun tasers may
be newer technology but questions of
force have come up before with other
police tools in the past we've had
problems with choke holds and then we
had problems with the use of weapons and
then they realize the pecans might kill
someone and they
keep changing the weaponry but the
problem is not the weapons the problem
is the officers do they know how to use
the weapons and when to use them and why
it's a question the Ninth Circuit Court
of Appeals recently asked well in
October the Ninth Circuit and a non
blank decision which means the whole
court decided a really important case
called Manos and in that case this court
for the first time said when you use a
Taser it may be a clear violation of
constitutional law the case that they
used was a case of a mother driving her
child to school and this mother was
seven months pregnant and the police
stopped her from going about ten miles
over the speed limit and she did not
want to get out of the car and she did
not want him to sign the ticket so you
know what they did they tased her not
once not twice but three times and she
turned around and sued and this time the
Ninth Circuit said if we look at all the
circumstances this really wasn't a
serious crime she was committing she
wasn't a threat to the police officers
they didn't have to use this type of
force this is what we call a
constitutional violation because tasers
are relatively recently adopted these
are some of the first cases that we're
seeing that address the circumstance of
whether it's proper to for police to
apply the Tasers to people in low-risk
situations I think it was time for the
court to send a clear message you can't
just use a Taser when you don't like the
suspect you think they're not being
cooperative or even if you're kind of
afraid of them you have to use them only
when there aren't other options and
there's an imminent threat
the Kephart case is not actually that
atypical for these taser cases when you
start to read them you see how often the
Taser is actually used for traffic
violations these are misdemeanor
offenses and being tased is a much more
serious impact than you would expect
when somebody's just speeding or even
going through a stop sign I think that
the Ninth Circuit's decision will
definitely have an impact on the Kephart
lawsuit now what the impact is going to
be is that all judges are now going to
give a closer look at whether it was
unreasonable conduct but one of the
issues in the Kephart case is that the
actual actions by the officers took
place before the decision in the Ninth
Circuit case and so those officers may
be able to claim like the prior officers
did the law wasn't well established the
San Bernardino County Sheriff's
Department recently bought 1,500 new
tasers for their officers they declined
our interview to talk about it but the
cap our trial could begin in late 2012
we're coming
get ready it'll all come out in court
and we're not gonna quit we're not gonna
quit
you